[Music]
in self-esteem issue news submitted by
you man lays a vision Oh imagine a bagel
shop went viral after yelling about
women treating him badly for being short
short guys are the best
wait so girls just come in here and they
buy bagels and they go hey you [ __ ]
short piece of [ __ ] no I need to show
you this video because it's [ __ ]
funny
cutter reminds me Jason isn't late
because he's short ya know it's a it's
so funny that it's actually sad what the
[ __ ] you flipped it on me real quick but
like that's how sad this man is sad man
so sad it's funny Leo said me a very
kidding dude
very sad man here we go this takes place
in New York the great why is it okay for
women to say oh you're five feet are
dating sites you should be dead that's
okay nobody women in general I've said
it on dating sites you think I'm making
that [ __ ] up yeah the same [ __ ] smart
with the fighting with oh wow
like they're going God or my father or
my voice you're not God or my father or
my boss I love looking good attack me
the accent makes it so much better
the tackle yes he's still going crazy
employee game they're laughing at him
he's very like his accent oh yeah I
reminds me of like he reminds me of like
Joe Pesci but not scary
yeah Joe Pesci's like six feet taller
than him I wonder what triggered him
like to just so this is what happened so
they're saying that he walked into this
bagel shop and that he was just like
whispering under his breath something
about like he can't [ __ ] do their jobs
and all this [ __ ] right so then I got to
the point where he started berating one
of the employee women so then does a
nineteen year old girl she ended up
saying something like hey man you gotta
stop cuz he was calling them stupid and
stuff what if they were like hey don't
be so short he's like sure sure tempered
gosh she's like hey you're short you got
a few more bucks I get this all the time
[Applause]
yelling which copy would you want the
short or the long the 19 year old that's
when we started seeing this oh man he
ends up speaking like you know women on
dating sites like that [ __ ] was so yikes
I just jumped out of nowhere he's like
taking out all of his life problems on
them because the 19 year olds like like
why are you treating her this badly or
whatever and then the heath takes
they're like why do women treat me badly
Oh to get to all women I can't put me on
tinder so the crazy that's when he got
tackled right and then after he got
tackled that's when the employee lady
was like like here here you go have a
nice day and then he's great and their
legs getting pissed off because then she
laughs at him and then he like throws it
but if he comes back and picks
dude we paid for that was like a child
it was so funny because when he was
talking to the dude did you see his
little tippy-toes go up like that the
problem right now Joe he's a couple in
the guys cab we were just doing an
exercise that resembled that move to
think about short guys and I'm only
talking about short guys who are
insecure about being short there's a lot
of short guys out there who are
confident that's in but people who are
short you think I'm someone constantly
thinking about how short they are yeah
oh man that [ __ ] gets funny it gets
funny or even tall guys - I mean it's
just a confidence thing but tall guys
would never feel unconfident though
always so actually no they do because
they're tall guys I want to feel shorter
so they bully yeah I just talked about
that Floyd they stand out too much and
they're hunchbacks they're still taller
than us so this [ __ ] went crazy viral
and then it even a Christy Teegan she
tweeted she was like this could be the
thing that drives me out of my house
where do I need a post up with my
camping trip whatever the comments
I like the Internet man yeah what are
they say damn usually when people rage
it's like oh I got to get out of there
but in this case I'm like oh I gotta get
a cup of coffee and a bagel there so I
could watch this [ __ ] go down and it's
not because he's short
like we're not making fun cause he sure
it's just me it's cause he sure idiot
you know what cuz there are short people
that are scary he's not scary to me he's
kind of goofy and also he doesn't even
seem that short but it's just his own
image of himself is that small yes cuz I
know smaller people or people that might
be smaller than him that are scarier
yeah I wouldn't [ __ ] with Bose I just
got scared
Bose is small like Maximus was very
scary the accent for the mob
it was like like like the whole New York
accent it's just like the crisis yeah
all I use oh yeah I ain't afraid of you
pal
I'm like I don't hear people say pal
give me great actor though I like yeah
you know we do have like rage moments
here in LA a lot too but I just feel
like this is such a New York
an East Coast stereotype of like people
yeah cussing at each other and going
crazy at restaurants and [ __ ] I think
with East Coast people there's a lot of
my East Coast friends they're a lot more
like in your face but then la people are
like we'll just stand afar and just yell
at each other and just like [ __ ] on each
other's moms or something funny I can't
pull up the comments I don't know why oh
yeah okay so aside from his like rage
issues is this becoming a gender issue
or whatever well he was making it into a
gendered thing but I think most of this
like the reaction to this is just like
damn just poor guy like his self so a
lot of people are just sad for him it is
sad yeah it's comical I find it funny
because he deserves this yeah cuz he's
doing it to himself
right I think is like just judging by
the video he looks older - so it's like
to have like you know I would feel like
for guys it's like your height or like
your weight or leave over girls - like
if that's an issue that's kind of like
hopefully resolved like by like maybe
before you're 30 but this guy looks like
older than that so like what what is
making him so like crazy that he's still
holding on to just him being short goes
from zero to 100 from like whatever is
happening here to him immediately
pulling out his insecurities yeah it's
like well you don't like that bagel well
I have a short dick you know what that
come from it just comes out of nowhere
that's me who knows someone in that
coffee shop might have found him
attractive before he even opened his
mouth yeah yeah she wasn't like maybe
even that nothing everyone and it looks
like they're his type I'm just sad that
his insecurity is shortness and not
premature ejaculation all these women
every time I get it and I immediately
come you want to make fun of that yeah I
premature ejaculator all the time I do
it every day
you see this [ __ ] bagel
you see I don't even come that big I
just see a hole in it just comes out
yeah it's a [ __ ] dollop you're gonna
laugh at a [ __ ] dollar I knew guys
like that who wanted to have strong
loads that was in security or dribblers
and they wish that they had stronger
look I thought the [ __ ] iPhone emoji
that like dude girls don't give a [ __ ]
bro no I want a dribble don't give me a
[ __ ] lo don't care it's like the best
thing on the world don't be insecure
about oh so they're saying here that
this guy ended up leaving that there was
like someone did call the cops because
of this altercation here but no one was
physically injured other than him
getting like tackled but there was no
charges present do like the tackle like
he requested a tackle and it came
immediately it fell on the floor that
was the cops were talking to the man
outside trying to get him to calm down
I like how we talk like this to go like
no one took him serious
the the guy that tackled him down he
didn't see him as a threat enough for
him to walk away he wanted to prove
something for him no like shut up and if
you walked away because if you really
thought he was a threat you'd stay there
and make sure he doesn't hurt anyone
yes there's like you tackled a little
kid yes no it's like the kid that plays
basketball that you're just like taller
than and you go what the best [ __ ]
that's what it was yeah I know you know
at the end after like when you eat the
whole food throwing thing and then he
was like yelling at the employees and
this woman was like trying to get him to
leave woman come on come on a woman was
holding him back
no like sort of like see what his body
language where he was like hold me back
hold you back but like he wasn't really
trying he was just like all bark and no
bite
I saw a guy short guy go crazy and stab
a security guard in a rave why yeah he
was like he was like a gangster or
whatever but it was funny because so
they got into a fight with a bunch of
like the security guys there because
they're like oh you guys are selling
drugs you got to leave or whatever right
and I was watching this all go down in
the smoking section and then
there was like a bench and this dude got
on top of the bench to talk down to the
guys oh just like four-foot dude going
on top of a [ __ ] bench so he could
look down like this and fight them Wow
yeah it was pretty funny I was like what
the [ __ ] this aerial attack yeah and
then they got into a big Rumble and yeah
start stuff yeah and then he was running
through their legs
xiety yeah saying like if I was this guy
that I felt that insecure about my high
piano just roll around in rollerblades
all the time
that's not all y'all roll it really tall
yeah it feels pretty good and go you go
kind of fast and you kind of like arrive
places and people don't even know how
you just arrived you weren't elevator
shoes everywhere dude I like those healy
but the role they play is like this tall
yeah I have these adidas that like I
like a centimeter tumor I could feel the
difference dude what is it about women
why do you why do you guys want tall
guys or like taller guys why don't you
watch short guys maybe it's like like
the protection are you going to feel
protective like you know short guy could
do that it is a known thing about chicks
or whatever that cuz that's one of the
characters is like oh yeah he was tall
he was handsome he had this and that and
it's like oh yeah tall is in that I
think people should just say what they
want it's like hey big titties only hey
have a big ass yeah I'm cool with that
I just like a guy who is proportioned
right if I had to choose I suppose what
is the right like there's like there's
like you know some people like I don't
know they're just like oh short arms I
might be I'm getting myself into a big
hole okay fine if I had to like put
together the right guy it's just like
you know his shoulder like if you know
say if like you were you have a smaller
frame you would kind of work out to kind
of proportional eyes stuff I think I
have a small head so like I just want to
make sure that like I don't have like my
thighs are bulging out and stuff like I
just want to be like nicely proportioned
where like my body doesn't feel awkward
so hopefully the guy that I get kind of
has that too about himself you know you
got a small hand people say have a small
like small skull it's like maybe two
times
you can't because she's next to another
small very small heads I have a gigantic
[ __ ] head oh yeah you actually do
yeah I got a crane catches him he's like
six more you match your [ __ ] like if
you'd lost your muscle lollipop oh yeah
lollipop what do you mean by lollipop
[Music]
[Music]